Tom barrack founder of colony capital is
also in charge of organizing the Trump
presidential inauguration exactly two
weeks from today so tell us over to see
in two weeks down you're going to see a
tribute to America so this president
will act has said very simple direction
that this is for the people and by the
people and allow them to breathe the
history of 200 years of what exists in
Washington that it's not about him it's
about the largest peaceful transition of
partisan power to ever transcend like
this in the world so I think what you're
going to see is a very soft touch
starting from tuesday to saturday of
american oriented events to self focus
on the things that are important to us
and and i have to tell you as you walk
through the memorials themselves you
become so astounded with the patriotism
and the brilliance of the founders and
that's really his focus he wants to get
back to work he wants America to rebel
and this change of power which is
awesome when you think that in five
seconds from President Obama the weight
of the world just evaporates from his
shoulders to the president-elect
shoulders sitting on the platform on the
west side of the Capitol it's an
unbelievable moment so it's part of the
genius of the Republic actually it that
happens so regularly and so in such an
organized fashion